what's going on everybody welcome to the
10th Monte Carlo video in this video
what we're going to be comparing is not
only the bus rate but also the profit
rate so both strategies can't stand to
lose the same amount of money if they
lose but this is definitely not the case
for gains one strategy is certainly
better at making gains and then also
life expectancy for the strategies is
slightly different but it depends on
what time frame you're looking at on a
short timeframe life expectancy is far
better with simple better but if you
have a long time frame maybe not
necessarily and certainly considering
the cost versus benefits I would argue
the double better is the superior method
so anyways with that let's go ahead and
compare the two of these not only with
going broke but also profits so
initially we were using the same
terminology for both of these was you
know broke count and doubler profits so
or I mean broke count for both of these
but now what I want to do is say double
our profits and then like doublers busts
or something like that so let's just get
rid of broke count and let's say doubler
underscore busts and then global doubler
underscore profits and then every time
it goes here let's just copy and paste
this doubler busts it adds one double or
busts and where's the other one double
or boss ok so now the other thing that
we want to know at the very end is did
we profit so run underneath
PLT top client will say if value is
greater than funds so if the value is
greater than the starting amount of
money that we you know started with then
we made a profit so that's good so we'll
just say double our underscore profits
plus equals one and that's it now we'll
take simpler better or simple better and
again instead of broke count we're gonna
call this simple underscore busts and
then we'll Global another variable again
both of these don't exist don't be
freaking out if you don't have him yet
simple underscore profits and then again
where he goes bust will or where he goes
broke count we're just gonna add this
I'm pretty sure he only had one yeah and
this is outside of this so don't get
confused okay and I think that's the
only place we had it on simple so anyway
and then we'll do the same thing and if
value greater than fun so again if he
has more money than he started with
simple underscore profits plus equals
one okay so the next thing that we're
gonna do is we'll keep x equals zero
that's fine and now we want to add in
all of these variables so we've got
simple underscore busts
equals zero point zero doubler
underscore double underscore busts
equals zero point zero simple underscore
profits equals zero point zero and
double leur underscore profits equals
zero point zero okay and then while X is
less than sample size we do want to run
simple better now color that's all good
I think we're all set in this so now the
next thing that we want to do is I'm
just going to delete these and we'll
keep the labels there but now we want to
print out the stuff that we find so
print and the first thing is going to be
simple better bust chances
: and this is just gonna be simple
underscore busts / sample size times 100
point zero zero and then again print
doubler better mm-hmm
Plus chance :
doubler underscore busts out of sample
size times 100 and then now we want to
know the profits so not only do we care
you know does somebody go bust but we
also care does somebody make a profit so
we want to do print oops
simple better profit chances and this
one is simple profits out of sample of
sample size again times 100 so the next
thing that we want is to print doubler
better profit chances and doubler
underscore profits over sample size
times 100 and that should be everything
the other thing that I like to add just
for kicks as we'll add this plot dot a
x-h line we'll add it at the zero and we
will color it red to signify use so that
should be enough I'm gonna go ahead and
delete this I don't foresee a time in
the future when we'll plot us that one
again alone I think we're good so let me
change wager count to a thousand just so
this comes up quicker and will even
change sample size to a hundred just
just for now so let's go ahead and run
that and see if we get any errors we do
not
and so we come over here and here's our
obviously our chart that we get and then
the next thing is so we can see how you
know good people did so simple better
bus chances zero not a single simple
better lost money so that's cool um
double or better bus chance 87% chance
of going bust so very high percent
chance of coming bus simple better
profit chances 33% double or better
profit chances 13% so across the board
with a thousand wagers we can see that
actually the double or better is the
better better based on these rules but
if you look at who at we know what kind
of profit are we talking right now we're
just asking about profit the next
question is of the people who profit
what multiple of their starting amount
is the typical profit because we can see
some people here are ending quite high
forty fifty sixty seventy well no one's
seventy but about sixty thousand is the
highest so obviously you stand to gain a
lot more with a doubler so the next
thing that we'd want to do is check will
add some more wagers to the actual
that's to shorter amount of wagers first
so let's run this we're only doing 100
wagers and we can see here quite a few
these guys drop off that's pretty funny
so again simple betters chances of going
bust the none double or betters chance
of going bust is a thirty percent chance
of going bust and then of the 31 percent
if you didn't go bust how likely is it
that you profited if you were a double
or well 61 percent which i think is
pretty cool so it's if you don't lose
you did darn well
whereas with simple better it only makes
sense to since you're doubling up right
with double or better simple better you
only still only have a 40% chance of
profiting here well thirty nine percent
chance of actually making a profit so
you know that better
just don't know what the point anything
that better is but you can see already
with a even though only a hundred wagers
so you thought you had 49% almost 50%
odds you would expect that at least
initially you might think well I stand a
50-50 chance of profiting but you don't
because each wager is knocking against
you so you can already see here that
actually only stand a full thirty nine
percent chance not even fourteen keep
wanting to say forty there
so anyway pretty interesting now let's
add let's do one more let's make the
sample size a little bit larger so it's
representative and we're gonna do 10,000
wagers so let's go ahead and run that
one should come up pretty quick be
different if we made a larger sample
size okay so we're simple better has an
84 percent chance of going bust our
doubler has a 98% chance of going bust
but here we can see if you didn't if you
were a double better and you didn't go
bust you made profit okay that's pretty
cool now hold on I'm refusing to believe
this simple better profit chances
eighty-five percent I can see this
visually is incorrect what have we done
now that's gonna throw off everything
now this one seemed about right but this
is definitely how could you possibly
profit
SuperBetter profit changes
well one thing is value equal zero there
and I'm not really sure why that is that
we sure can't be putting in broke there
let's see value I'm just so confused at
how we could actually have a tease
it's so obvious that that's incorrect so
I'm very angry sample size would go back
to one hundred and a thousand there I
could have possibly just been the fact
that we were putting in broke which is
not like a valid digit prophet changes
24
c13 okay that should do it
so hopefully that was the only issue yes
we're not doing like complex math here
so I'm a little concerned but I think it
was possibly just the fact that we made
value
yeah we've set value to equal something
that's exactly I think what we've done
because we set value up here to equal
broke which wasn't even a digit and then
you at we were asking is value greater
than funds and maybe it was saying that
it was greater than funds because it
wasn't even that number I don't know
anyway these are a little bit better
numbers anyway simple better profit
chances 26 percent that's a little bit
more in line with what I was expecting
so let me go back up here I'll pause it
again I just want to run it will run
10,000 samples with 10,000 I guess a
thousand with 10,000 wagers let's see if
we get what we expect again I'll pause
it while this runs alright so this is a
little bit better this is what I was
expecting so the chances of going bust
84% doubler betters bust chance ninety
nine point four percent and then if you
didn't go bust you made a profit again
as the doubler a simple better profit
chance one point six so that's more in
line not an eighty percent so that's
good how we saw that you see this guy
went under again anyway that's okay I'm
not too focused on the simple better
anyways he's more of a control variable
for us so so that's okay we'll just
stick with that so now the next things
that I really want to do are get to what
we've been talking about and that is it
how successful is the double better is
that the best strategy to use if it is
the best strategy to use how many wagers
should you use and in direct correlation
to wagers or in direct relation to the
number of wagers I'm going to go ahead
and you're saying logically I know that
the amount of waiters that you
and also the size of your entire purse
starting plays a huge crucial role I
know it plays a role I just don't know
what exact what the exact role is and so
that's the that's the most important
thing that we're trying to find now
because was simple better the chances of
actually profiting you have a chance of
profiting by the actual profit that you
make is pretty miniscule as compared to
the profit that you would make as the
double better and so the double better
most likely at a wager size of say a
hundred is gonna be one of the better
choices let me make sure I closed out
the plot yeah because you stand to gain
much more and so it might be the case
that so here we go right here
double better profit chances you have a
sixty six percent chance of profiting
whereas a simple better even though he
won't go bust he only has a thirty eight
percent chance of profiting and we can
already see us that with the double or
better he didn't actually dolt I mean a
few guys got close but he made good
profits
whereas our simple better maybe made
twenty percent right so we didn't really
make that much money but our doubler if
you did profit you made pretty darn good
money since we were kind of up in this
area and then obviously we have a lot of
losers that dropped off here but your
bust chance is only thirty percent and
so of that thirty percent you're a sixty
six percent chance to profit so saying
you had 100 grand you would just start
with ten thousand each time you would
bet as a double or better and just play
out 100 wagers or and or bust and at the
end of 100 wagers you'd start over say
I've got ten grand I'm gonna do another
hundred wagers and on a long-term scale
you might actually make a profit we're
gonna answer all these questions and
we're also going to be looking for the
correct answer of how much should our
starting wage for being a percentage to
our full funds how many wagers should we
do maybe that maybe the ideal wager
number is 80 or 82 and then also
what's the multiple so right now we're
multiplying by two but it might be
something else so that's what we're
going to be working on in the next
videos we're gonna make a double or
better but basically we're gonna make
all of these things variable so first
we're just gonna do the multiple we're
gonna try and make one variable first
and then as time goes on we're gonna
make it
switch up all of these variables like
how big of a wager size to start with
how many wagers to do all of that
probably the last one we do is how many
wagers to do so first will will vary a
it will add the variable for the
multiple then we'll do the starting size
probably and then we'll do wager count
at the very end and each time what we
use the Monte Carlo simulator to do is
just run through all of these examples
over and over and over and over and over
find one that's successful test it like
about a thousand times to make sure it's
actually successful and then we've got
an answer so that's what you guys have
to look forward to all of you guys are
enjoying I'm kind of enjoying it it's a
lot of fun to like look through all of
these examples so anyway I'm having a
good time so anyway that's what you guys
have to look forward to as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions
until next time